[Music]
okay singing was like and when they've
got a big fan of country star Lauren
Alaina in fact Lauren's love foreplay
goes way back to for Idol days
look how young she is good that you can
group photos yeah it's very sweet it's
so sweet but now she's 22 years old and
is featured on Kane Browns hit single
what it the song is helping to make him
the first country artist atop all five
of Billboard's country music charts but
a ztl line so Keisha lacy found out
Payne and Lauren's connection goes back
even further than that
[Music]
Kanan Lord actually grew up together in
Georgia we were awkward kids in middle
school we lived in a small town and I
don't think anybody else's how to do it
was somebody from a small town that's
what number one or Platinum's I think
it's a cool experience in less than two
years the 23 year old went from working
at FedEx and posting songs on Facebook
to being nominated for an ACM award and
he's about to celebrate another big
milestone his upcoming wedding with
fiance Kaitlyn next fall how was the
wedding planning going she's doing it
I'm saying yeah that's the correct
answer
does your fiance ever get emotional with
your music she did over the song I wrote
for thought what's mine is yours
what's mine play like 50 times I kind of
got tired of do you rock out to your own
music oh yeah yeah yeah I tried it's
weird I get in my car and like to drive
and kind of listen to the songs to see
if if I jam out to it this is anybody
else would
one thing that we've never guessed by
looking at you I'm not a rapper I bet he
can rap too yeah well you can see more
from Keynes interview in an upcoming
episode of surf I country scene new
episodes every Friday on e t--'s
Facebook page
[Music]
you